my guest tonight of course a cast member
on star not live for many years he also
started on the very funny showtime
series
white famous his latest movie all my
life is in theaters
right now we are thrilled he could be
here
in person tonight please welcome the
very talented jay
pharaoh jay thanks for being here oh
thank you thank you so much i usually
walk out
i have this like sexy walk out that i do
but i couldn't do it because i was
already placed
yeah yeah i know i i didn't want you
doing the sexy walk out because i
couldn't handle it last time
oh yeah it was a little too much it it
tempted me in ways i've never been
tempted so i said this time i want jay
sitting for the interview ahead of time
amazing
no sexy walk for you oh man ever again
missed opportunity
i got to ask you a bunch of questions
because i don't know anybody that's
been traveling anywhere you just got
back from
mauritius yes in africa yes
what's it like over there right now it's
coveted free there's no kovi they have
no covet and mauritius they have no
covet in mauritius whatever so it's it's
uh
mauritius whatever it's it's so nice to
be able to hug
people and uh so they're hugging and
they're not hugging
uh face touching um whatever
you know what i mean eating off your
sandwich you know i mean drinking your
juice you know i did all of that it was
so much fun
you know what i miss is eating off
someone else's plate that's something i
did all the time
very rude but i did it when they don't
ask you yes no i just
and i would take like mashed potatoes
off someone else's plate no fork
no fork just my hand that was
that was what i used to do now
everyone's you can't touch my plate
you might have covid i get i'm the same
way
it was nice it was nice over there i
would tell you this though
the the insects out there are insane
okay the
insects the insects out there are like
gangsta
jack like for real like the insects here
in america
are like will smith the insects over
there are like 50 cent but like
not 50 cent now republican 50. we're
talking about
i just got shot in the cheek 50 cents
i still have the rabbit teeth uh i will
still pop caps in
asses 50 cents you know what i mean so
street cred fitty cent
street crate not wearing like a polo
pullover and
voting for trump not abercrombie and
fitch trump supporting 50 cent
no that guy not that guy right it was a
freaking centipede
in in my villa and when me and my family
got in the villa
we opened the door and the centipede
just walked out like oh my bad i know
y'all was coming today
i had you coming tomorrow i apologize oh
my bad people
i didn't clean up you know were you
there
in africa during the u.s elections i was
what was that like to watch those
returns come in oh my goodness because
it was tense here in america i don't
know what it's like to be
in africa it's dude it was it was so
crazy and
and the fact that when he finally did
win
uh we were hugging because we could but
here in america you all hugged as well
and you weren't supposed to
no y'all were all outside hugging
kissing eating each other's fries butt
slapping
all of that all right slap so many
people that slap just
so many all up in the videos this is
like suge night you know
all up in the videos dancing
touching were you not supposed to i know
it was a momentous moment it was a
momentous
joyous moment when it happened but i
felt sorry for y'all because i knew you
all couldn't celebrate the same way well
that's the problem is uh people
momentarily forgot about kovid yeah when
biden won
they literally they conan they act like
after the election
covet was like oh oh yeah my job is done
i'm out of here that's not what happened
covey was like y'all think i'm a hoax
oh okay well you get coveted you get
covered everybody gets covey covert is
basically like oprah the way he just
touched people
you put some covet under your seat i put
coven under your seat
you can check it yeah it was yeah
i was i felt sorry for you all that you
all couldn't couldn't hug and
and be intimate like we were but now you
know one thing i was thinking about
this morning is we now have a new vice
president yeah we'll be sworn in soon
kamala harris yes you do uh a a very
good uh kamala
impression yes and you know i do have a
kamala harris
impression and the key to it is actually
sounding like you just left happy hour
because
because i'm lit i am so lit i am so lit
like when she was when she was walking
that morning and she called up joe biden
yeah
hi joe you won we
did it i was like yo she just had a
picture of bloody mary's that's what
happened
like she had to walk so she could walk
off the bloody marys that's how it works
literally man she just sounds turnt
she's she's turt she looks good
she's blendy and it all works out yeah
yeah i like it i like black and indian
blending
you're uh are you did i hear correctly
that you are working
on a uh a new impression joaquin
phoenix's joker is that right i am now
what is the key to doing
joaquin phoenix's joker totally losing
your mind uh
eating uh eating an apple a day no no
you don't have to do that don't
please don't do the joaquin phoenix diet
you will not live okay yeah
he's different all right he's not from
here that was scary skinny
he was yo you could literally see his
heart from his backbone
like it was so crazy but he was
translucent yeah it was you could see
through him
because he was so he was the key to it
though
conan is you know basically
you have to switch your voice and talk
like this
it's not hard they just think we'll just
sit there
that we won't werewolf and go wild we'll
just take it like good little boys
you think guys like thomas wayne care
about people like me
they don't you know that means so and
the key to it like i'm saying another
key
always stay in character in my house so
i'm in house
doing things is why king phoenix you
know washing dishes um
cooking intercourse whatever you need
you know what i mean i mean that's i
mean that's wild though you know why i
can't fix some girls like it you know
what i mean it'd be like sure
yeah hit the yeah hit me with your
impression i'm like you like that
don't you oh my god is that why keen yes
it is and i've been bad but you've been
more bad naughty
[Laughter]
also stops you from climaxing if you
need you know you can always
you can always pull that out it stopped
me right there yeah
i was ready to go yo can i tell you this
once i really did this with my
ex-girlfriend right
you know it was a little too great and
um
it was a little too good and um i was
like yo you gotta slow down yeah i mean
but you know women don't
listen sometimes right we do people
people don't listen
exactly exactly both men and women both
men and women
but she ain't want to listen so i had to
pull out the jay-z real quick and i
laughed
and then that made her stop you know
what i mean you do with jay-z laughing
that makes everything stop that makes
everything stop like she
i was like yo chill slow down she was
like nah nah i was like yo chill
slow down she was like nah i was like
she was like why did you do that she
just ran in the corner
she was like why didn't you you're so
stupid why did you do that
i was like yeah cause i still want to
keep going that's why
that shuts it down that's probably tough
for jay-z when you think about it
oh my gosh probably shutting things down
for him yeah i mean that's the
i mean i wouldn't be turned i wouldn't
be turd
[Laughter]
shout out to jay i love jay-z i love it
i don't have to say that he's not
watching
maybe um now is this right you coined
i'm i'm
told yeah that you know everyone this
year this was the year of so many things
but karen's yeah karen's being out of
control and it became this whole thing
online
check out the karen losing it the
maskless karen the karen screaming at
the walmart
you coined the term karen for the white
woman being uh called karen yes
yes i don't know if there's any other
people before that you know what i mean
so you you think you you were the first
one to do it a while ago i think i was
the first one to do it a while ago for
the white women being named karen
because you know i grew up in the
suburbs so i'm i'm used to that
yeah i mean it was always caring's
around me when i was growing up you knew
a lot of karen's growing up a lot of
karen's when i was growing up you know
and they always uh
they would always talk and um uh that
that's
that's black people repellent you know
what i mean them talking
is black people neighbor repellent
what's the kind of thing that karen
would ask you
if you know you had moved into the
neighborhood oh she oh
oh so are you renting are you buying
really okay so you're in that big house
by yourself
yes i am you want to be my maid
is that why you keep asking me for
there's karen's all around me now you
know i live
i live in the burbs again you know what
i mean it took a couple i lived in the
burbs and i went to the hood and i moved
back to the burbs that's how i did it
you know what i mean i had to get the
experience i'm coaching you know what i
mean
but the karen's i know were like jill's
and and barbara's and all of that they
just they're
they're carrying anything it's a carrot
it's a carrot doesn't matter
they're out there they're out there
cameron's are out here uh let's talk
about this in in all my life this is a
true story
all my life and you play uh you know a
good friend best man
to this character will you set it up for
us because this is this is a powerful
story
yes so jen and saul have a relationship
well
jen saw they were in love with each
other they have these friends
jen uh jen and saw they get engaged
they're about to get married saul finds
out he has cancer
and they use all of the money for
chemotherapy and whatever and they
they are not going to have a wedding so
the community
sees the story they do a gofundme they
all donate and they do this big wedding
for this couple it's really so when did
this happen 2015
yeah it happened it's a very cool story
and we have
we have a clip here which i think you
are the best man and i think
uh and in every respect you are the best
man yeah hey thank you
appreciate that yes it had to be said
yeah because you asked me to
um
[Laughter]
it's gonna be perfect just like you and
jen
maybe not as perfect as my margarita but
what's this open it
find what you love and do it don't wait
dude he's on fire wasn't that amazing
we don't have the resources to actually
they just saw the clip okay okay
you and i didn't see the clip i saw the
clip earlier and you know the clip
because you're in the clip
right i know the clip i did because i
did the scene i did the movie and it
it was it's a nice sweet story it's
another side of me
it's a dramatic side and i mean there's
some fun in there in the beginning but
i mean the the whole the whole message
of the story is to enjoy life
no matter because you don't know how
long you have here you know and
and that's proven even with this year
with covet but the fact that you're here
now
appreciate those moments and just make
the most of them
and thank god you're here yeah you know
so amen
that's what i try to do you know
whatever and always make sure your
jacket matches the furniture
always make sure that i tried but you
nailed it
yo literally i could disappear you only
see
i'm a floating head you're a floater
there's this floating head in front of
me
quite good-looking floating head in
front of me just and the rest just
disappears
uh i wondered why you called ahead and
wanted to know exactly
what color the chair was uh all my life
is a great story it's in theaters now
and it's going to be available on video
on demand and digital
december 23rd
and is there anything else i thought
there was something else i will tell you
this
conan is like come on jay i'm like yo i
want to hear it i have a project that
i'm dropping
where uh i'm doing impressions i'm
rapping doing impressions
and doing my own features so i'm like
i'm like doing the impressions and i'm
rapping as well you know what do me a
favor when that comes out come on back
because i'd love to talk to you again
let's do it you are hilarious
i love talking to you jay farrell thank
you so much for being here thank you
cohen
i bow to you socially distanced
yes i give it all i spit at you